hello and welcome to the
press room of the european commission in
direct presence but also thank you for
following us also live
on robin wright today is
friday february 11
let me start by
giving you details on the agenda of  the
president art form hatred for
next week it will be another
busy week this and so on monday the
president will receive the president of
the republic of columbus gentlemen
ivan two cases mark in mourning on
tuesday she will be in strasbourg de
meetings
weekend and
his channel on one day of president will
be in my blog germany all the doors
hindi vaccine equity for africa launch
events
korhogo nice bye bye bye bye
andy keane has melted
into a phase of mou ni de prizren team
will be back in both  ways to receive
aptel fatah lcc de president of the arab
republic of it gets in the states will
receive but it may be that at the fia
the prime minister of china a j  ohn
foster got between the president in
place hindi or african union summit a
very important
we expected to preserve this pitch
administration of the seas munich
security conference on dance hall at
200 da for 1 explains that we need
corinthians
then but all
our  colleagues first of all
the
respective studies to the world you
habib sabaly shop truth
leave a
space in service on
the horizon ni
[Music]
gas
you know there will be looking carefully
ab science fiction of marquette
of the hubris you'  ve been found claude
rich or die
[Music]
of state of gas
sales date viewfinder all but each two
historical figures
[Music]
of the
logic
of the notes taken including
our country who
told us
[  Music]
and
[Music]
melzer we believe in
you
conclusion
weather redemption is it
on a
daily basis thanks to the Spanish market
would you do conclusion
date
[Music]
des on dit
investigation d'ailleurs conta  cté
regarding competition
when
we stand out from
closing
[Music]
christian blazy
yes absolutely
in fact I would like to know if the
commission asked gazprom for
explanations on the fact that there was
I would say not a drying up but a
slowness in responding to
supply requests from a number
of member states Germany, for example,
has just discovered with a growl
that it has a very,
very, very low level of reserves, which is of concern to them, they
have actually asked  to their
main supplier to deliver
gas to them and it doesn't come do you
know why any submitted that the
technical issues that
actually prevent gazprom from supplying more
gas thank you thank you very much for
bringing questions to christian this is not
technically a  question for ariana
who who also takes care of if you
want other aspects of a discussion with
gazprom but about the functioning
of the markets  és
but this is a question that will be rather
poor
steam but we are talking here if you want
bilateral contacts between
member states and is a company so I
wonder if tim has news on
the state of the
deaths contacts at the bilateral level n  have
not necessarily but in general I
can just say that we
send a lot of messages through all the channels
that we have on the need for
gazprom
to honor its contracts and guards and
the levels of reserves at the
limits which allow a good
gas supplies from us as an
important customer because we are
an important customer for gazprom so from the
point of view of the volume of gas that
gazprom
supplies to us so we want
gazprom to
have a good
commercial partner who
obviously respect the contracts but  also the
commercial logic which says that in case of
need it is absolutely necessary to
increase the gas flows towards towards us
that's all we have to say
enough  z enough subject of accounts
with the company I see that oliva
also a question on this subject go to
lebanon
earlier hi rather on
relations vis-à-vis ukraine so it is
rather a political question therefore  I
can come back a little later it's not
really directly on the gas
so I launched once again the
possibility for colleagues to
ask questions about the gas to see
if there is any  the interest I do
n't see so thank you ariana and oliva you can
go there your question on the
calculation
leadership
and phil ochs to our contract
indra we fight explain
that he is better
he
rectifies a sum than
[Music]
[Music  ]
our man is
pockmarked
ukraine and
checked
baggage is locked
us policy and
dry
life at
280 december 9
krajina
bishop
[Music]
madness
while typing an export deposit
final offers will be
[Music]
taken
in
ukraine still has its prospects
Ukraine he had just made this
ass  ture fatickois on carpet like click
the open audiophiles good hope in east
however
their
safety instructions if you 7 knots it
is
possible to associate political premium
one of the
economic pieces the distillates poté nice to
be
continuous
from the police
watch police and
[Music]
problems
and to
this entry
[Music]
it came close
to depriving evening woodside 26
it's questions be first
it's on the  ukraine but it's not a
follow-up on a partnership to peter has
already been very clear on that no what
i want to know pieters and if you
share the same alarmist analysis
of the united states of the united kingdom of nato
on the imminence of  a
russian military intervention and the need
to evacuate the nationals of the countries
means that president mbaye dème and
bim kane announced that today
sacem a little bit at a time the cold
and at the same time it bothers a little bit
in  I'  analysis because we have
the impression that pretty Europeans even
if we are concerned or rather confident
in President Macron's mission to
solve the problem
thank you Christian the most important thing as
soon as they are
naturally concerned with us by the
military concentration of  the part of russia in
the ukrainian border we are
calling there also for a de-escalation
to do all the actions impossible
for one to have the de-escalation
situations we continue to be engaged
in the process of dialogue of the
commitments to find the solution of
this crisis in  a
diplomatic way in a political
and peaceful way on the evacuations each
country has on its own conditions its
own criteria the own motivations
to decide on the evacuation on the
level of wages for us as
European Union and the member countries of
the European Union  we will continue our
operations at the creams as we
have done j  until today
of course we are in the course of
what is happening in the environment
of ukraine we follow the
developments of the situation
carefully we do our
planning in a very very
strict and very very  sensitive and we
evaluate the situation regularly
also in the coordination with the
member countries which are represented in Ukraine
but as I say we have a planning
for all the scenarios this for all the
situations campinchi planning but but
as I say we continue our
operations
normal in a way how
we did from the beginning of this crisis
there thank you peter is indeed we
are constantly evaluating this with also our
member states present on the
spot is there any other question for
peter on this subject
zhao know  it's not about tommasone
tommaso
connectique
brigaud
attacks
the
timing proves
[Music]
if you're it
continues
to complicate life with
just conflict hâ  you
to be elbow to elbow and
[Music]
crisis marketing
and to continue stopovers public
service it's up to you
by presenting borel to be broadcast yesterday
if I understood correctly to
his equivalent lavrov in russia peter
is this  that you can give us
elements on the substance of this of this
missive and more exactly if there is
something new in the
compositions the ideas which will
make it progress will make it progress in relation to
what we have already repeated abundantly
like the main principles in particular
those which were approved during the said
munich of brest thank you
very much very difficult question for peter to
reveal the content of the diplomatic missions
when I indicated yesterday we are
not going to really share all the content
of these messages  from the part of the member countries
of the european union as the
representative has already said we have
transmitted we have given an answer
to all the concerns in flat written messages
home before yesterday the answer  nse was
remy part to representative borel at the
base of the
decision apart unanimously from any member country of
all sizes many europeans
the soul if you want the first message
decided this of this letter it was
a
reinforcement of our determination of
our  from our position that we are
ready to continue the dialogue with
russia
on ways to strengthen
security in the euro that's the one
I advise that's the substance of this
fall of being and we are ready  to
continue this dialogue in the interest of de-
escalation in this
in the sense of the policy of finding a
solution especially the crises all the
problems before the negotiating table
thank you very much maybe I see that
christian to a question asked question
is what  we can connect question
it works hear here but peter thank you
in fact I would like to come back
to philippe's question it may seem
anecdotal but there is a part that
is actually public  we have the impression and
it is a rather firm tone on the part of
mr bourrel lavrov had written a
certain number of his counterparts to
ask them for explanations on a
position all that is well known but
he had explicitly asked for
answers  national and not a response
in blocks outside the European Union
responded in blocks and Mr. Morel gave
him a text explanation in his
letter I wanted to know is
it just an exchange
that will have no impact or
do we risk with this story
of derailing the possibility of having
exchanges at the level of the west and them
since if I understood correctly Mr.
Lavrov said if the European Union
answers us as a whole
I  don't want to participate in
discussions so that's where we are
all the same in a rather
serious story soul anecdotes and the fleury tone
discover thank
you thank you christian as Thursday at
the dance is a member of the
european union have decided  that we will respond
in a unified manner by a letter
written and signed by the high representative
of the european union for foreign policy
laouni ners the
european union has 100 own
foreign affairs policies
foreign affairs policy is based in
unanimous consensus fight so if the wind
seven member countries decide who they want
they are going to respond that way
it is a decision of
independent country sovereign countries so if you are
really interested in a de-escalation
in a dialogue you pay l  the intention
to the company is not to the form
but it is up to us to decide
which form we are going to answer so
if dialogue but go ahead
yes maybe on purpose but does
every 27 year old remain the same letter and
why  we did not choose to answer
within the west this letter
because it concerns the water charter it is
this jury thank you
there answers the message written as the
tricks call this communication
original in front of January 8 I think
was addressed one of the russia part
was going to minister of foreign affairs
of some european countries
the united states and I think canada also
so he addressed
several countries is the country which are
who received the russian letters from the
european union have skipped a european country and
we have decided that we are going to respond not
one by one but by a common response in
front of it is therefore it was the 27 countries which
have decided
in their will in the receiver
indicated we are going  produce a single letter
as we formulate our positions in
foreign policy also in
the european union which is formulated is
pronounced is transmitted to the handed over by the
high representative for foreign policy
and the same this effect by nato for
example so we have coordinated
with eads partner in the fall
thank you very much peter i see a
question from david which would relate to this
subject
thank you dana clown it's a flop to
christian's question  if I
understood correctly yesterday the minister the voice will say
he simply said it will spoil the
discussions
the collective response
is that
you the Russians warned us of
this possibility and do you
have a reaction in relation to that  i
just want to say that the
negotiations on the issue
i wouldn't like to comment i wouldn't like
to comment on all of
messi's remarks at once because many times
it really doesn't make any sense but
our position is very clear
member countries  the member states of the
european union received a letter with
some requests with some
questions and it was decided to respond to
mr. lavrov in a unified way
by the letter a sign
to the representatives of bourrel
road reaction I also passed but that is
worth  read the letter when he knows
pronounced on on the form like thursday if
you are interested in
to find solution in a
crisis solution of a request in a
peaceful manner  fic normal diplomatic policy
as is normal in heavy in
europe in the
in the year 2022 so in the in a
modern time you are not focusing
on the form but you are going to read the
content reflect on the proposals
and c  is our message the letter that
was forwarded to rummy speaks to the
reps contains messages
from ben he is a member of the european union
thank you very much peter
fill it to a follow up question go ahead
philips
actually follow up for
stayed on  this thematic response to
27 and more initiatives sometimes
more individual how is the
coordination the consultation where the
solos occur
4:06 p.m. with the missions of the
macro president and the next week of the
German Chancellor is what there also
in a way  that he speaks on behalf of the
27 or else a form of freedom is
granted to these two large member states
which are also part of the normandy format
thank you for
the visits l  The bilateral engagement
is part of the
general European efforts because
each visit each chamber interview
telephone call from the party of a
leaders of the European member countries
transmitted the same message the message
the call for escalations the messages
to continue the dialogue  and not
try to find solutions in
dialogue so it's like the
foreign policy of the European union work
we are going to European positions which are
transmitted by the by the representatives
of the European union of the
European institution for example
and also  by the minister of foreign affairs
or the chancellor or the
presidents of the individual member countries
so it's all part of our
general efforts to find the solution
to continue the dialogue with
russia to try engaged with
russia to discuss all  the worries
that russia has
in a proper way is in a
form in in a proper platform
like co
mrs i say there the answer of mr morel it is a proof of the very united girl positions is very common of the european union created by all the member countries of the european union thank you much later and to strengthen again with also examples what pcd on the coordination of our position which is a united position there are different messages is actually who carry these messages to moscow or to kyiv or elsewhere during their journey but there is constant coordination between and its messengers from the european union and she remains so as an example I can tell you that for example this week the president founded the hatred was a telephone contact with president macron and with the chances and things because you mentioned these two countries so I'll give it to you as an example, but it also very often has intense contact with all the other member countries and also with other partners, so we have a  no
united position and we are very coordinated
before after and during the various
training meetings and
discussions that take place and which involve
representatives of the european union
does he have any other questions on this
yes christian
guy pieters  I don't want to seem like a
nitpick, but what I miss, if
you want, is this press release, this
declaration signed by Mr. Morel,
who could perfectly well not have reacted
to Mr. Lavrov's remarks, but who
really insists and denounces a
will  to divide the european union
it is not the first time that josep
borrell has denounced russia's desire to
marginalize the european union
as such to refuse to treat it
as a serious blog to rather want to
deal with a certain number of  these
individuals I will there is a meaning in
this letter if not why the balance
and 11 years of history if that's if that's what
I don't understand
I'm afraid I want to repeat that I  have
already said to the decision of member countries
before its member states of the
european union were we will respond
in a way that we have done by
a letter signed by the representative
it is the decision of the european union
in line in  in the in
the spirit of the foreign policy of
the european union it is that i can
say all that
thank you very much philippe
one last question after all
these explanations is what the feeling
or the analysis that we are doing today  today
is that the dialogue
the diplomatic efforts continue where
we have reached the end of course we
continue we hope that the
ministry the front will study she will read
the letter will try to understand the
content of these letters our
continuous efforts to  find a solution
in a civilized way because we
are in europe in the year 2022 and it is
a soul plan that we can take
find a solution of diplomatic engagement
and you also see the
calendar  visits
commitments interactions between them there are
different member countries of the
european union with russia so we will
continue and we will continue
because we are determined we have the
determination to continue the
diplomatic engagement to find a solution
that  benefit all all security
in europe all all countries in seven
continents
thank you very much above does he have
any other questions on this subject
I do not see so I pass the floor to
joe joe gaillette
and
as these
[  Music]
two positions
lionel if we don't have to go
yes no it's not for peter in fact
so these cases I will be a last
call for interest for questions on
foreign affairs for peter
I don't  don't see thank you very much peter you
're going to win weekends and now we'll hand over
to lionel
yes dana it's just a small question
of clarification in relation to the
agenda announced what in relation to the
day  rned the President's agenda on Wednesday
just before the briefing and
had a briefing on the parliament side where it was
announced that on
Wednesday afternoon a debate was going to be
organized in parliament on the as a
result of the court ruling on the
regulation  conditionality the
Hungarian appeal the Polish and there was
question in any case never
announced to us that president van der weyden would take
part in this debate on Wednesday at 4
p.m. in fact you told us that on
Wednesday she will be in marburg for a
meeting with bio ntech I  believe or
things like that so I want to know what's
going on just a clarification
thank you yes thank you very much for your
question lionel it's that I announced
the start of this meeting that's the point
on the agenda  which was confirmed so
when I came here in the
press room obviously there are also other
points from a jean da from the president which
are being discussed but
there have not been any specific conclusions
which per me  put to say the art and the
moment seventeen others of his other
commitments and as you say the agenda of
the plenary of the parliament was stopped for a
moment until we went down so
I did not have the exact information on
that  obviously we are looking at
participation in this plenary which which
is which has just been
confirmed and we will come back to
you with details gt1 been clarified
that the meeting
on vaccines the event on vaccines
with africa that I was operating which  takes
place in
marburg germany and takes place on wednesday
morning so and at the same time as I
said we are studying other agenda items
to see how we can organize ourselves
so that the president participates
in other important moments including
obviously these debates which is an
important debate that will take place next week on
wednesday afternoon
does he have any other questions about this
agenda
l'éveil hollande said
yes on the agenda because i am
really puzzled i  life  ns to attend the
briefing of the parliament of the parliamentary groups
yesterday the hour a little more than their
they announced that the presidency will be there and
in addition it is a very relevant political question
of which the president I cannot in
my opinion  would be drawn to answer what to
do with poland hungary and
above all we saw that the parliament is
not happy that the proof that the
commission has not yet triggered the
procedures against the two countries so
it has failed this and that tel there  is it
more important for her to attend
a summit a bit more let's say
on vaccines even if it's important
or is it more important to
go personally or by mans by
representing  the European commission
as guardian of the treaties etc but in
addition in the chat there are twenty questions
from our colleague I think
approaching the only one in doves
located just to clarify the
plannings for the meeting with the
Colombian president for  r she thank
you thank you very much for reviving olive
we want them I had hoped that I had
cleared you but Friday of which therefore as I
have just told you the president a
commitment Wednesday every morning and
that we were discussing how
the  plenary of the parliament which was
confirmed in fact just before I
went to the press room on mentioned
an hour ago indeed that is
approximately where we started here so I
did not have the logistical details of the
seven participations  but i would like to
thurey to hasten to reassure
you personally that this is a debate which is very
important for the commission it is
of course a subject which is very important
for the commission and for the president
you know how we invest
politically legally  and in
terms of working cooperation
with member states in the subjects
is rights so we will be
able to confirm once I
leave this meeting these new points on
the agenda q  who are we and who are
in very advanced discussions
on colombia actually i wanted to
come back to mira paravent there too i
don't have exact soul and logistical confirmations
of a possible
press briefing but i will come back to
you once  it is confirmed when
you know the president and in brest she
was gone for 4 days or three
days elsewhere in africa so
this afternoon we are going to take stock of
all the other
aspects of the calendars which must be
clarified and for that we will let you know  pass
the information quickly
david
yes thank you one more
year about this event chief
biotech
i was looking on the biotech site for
the information but
i can't find it i wanted to know if
who else if it is  possible for you
to tell us obviously who else is
going to participate
in this event people at the
political level of Africa and I have a
second question
because I can see that the President has
a very  special with
files and biotech but above all biotech we
are of course during his visit to
dakar
with the project with the pasteur institute
and vaccines with mrn na technology but
biotech is not the only company in
the european union
kiki who are trying  or who manufactures
vaccines
so i wonder
why all this
i mean is what good
text has become there
the european commission vaccine manufacturer
why this
advertisement this insistence on biotech
no other players in the market even
s  'they are from other continents like
modern art
where other pharmaceutical companies who
are based in the european union
thank you very much david for stretching
questions first on the event which
will take place in
hammarberg on wednesday morning i don't  I don't have
the details in mind because we are
not the ones who are organizing,
we are participating as guests in this
event which brings together African heads
of state and governments with
ec political representatives of
the European Union and financial institutions
of the European Union if I
remember correctly the goals being to
continue cooperation
under the aegis of vaccine and
African criticism are you
probably aware of the extent  of our
commitment to support not
only vaccination in africa but also
the building of a capacity to
produce vaccines in africa and as
you may also know biotech it is
a descent taken over from companies that
invest in africa  in order
to be able to mount and increase the
capacity of our African partners
to produce vaccines so that is the
global context in which these
events take place but indeed
it is from them of the organizers that
you will obtain more information on
who  is there but the idea is precisely African
heads of state and government
and political representatives
of the European Union and
also if I'm not mistaken
the organi  world health station which
is a part an important partner
in these projects also on the second
part of the state questions on bayrou tech
quite simply david I invite you to
look at the figures of the wedges
companies have delivered how many vaccines
to the union  european to european union
countries i don't have them with me
but i can tell you from memory
or guesses based on
if you want trends
so far i think we must have delivered
about a million 1  billion and a half
doses for the country of the European union
and when I tell you that stéphane
checking the exact figures
but the last time I mentioned
the figures it was 1.4 billion so
we should be around a billion  and a half
is actually you can see in these
figures that bryant and faïza c1 is the
supplier of the most
important vaccines with regard to the
volumes of doses that have been delivered to the
countries of the european union for for
for  various reasons
first of all I was a signal we concluded the
contracts with
vaccine suppliers on the basis of the interest of
the member states to buy one vaccine or
the other I can remind you of the
processes in which we have
which  led us to select
potential vaccine suppliers to
establish contracts with them to
negotiate contracts with them and everything was based
on the choice of member states on the
quantities of vaccines from one supplier
on deezer or
the other that he wanted  buy so we
the european commission we
coordinate and we conduct the
negotiations but it is not us who
decide which vaccine the member states
want to choose
they want to offer their citizens
so here it is perhaps also linked to
the capacity of the  productions of the modes and
the producers of the vaccines which also
led the member states to make
choices of the types of thil of vaccines but
also of the quantities but that is the
context that  e I remind you
frame our negotiations with
pharmaceutical companies in europe who
deliver vaccines for europe 1 you
have another question david go ahead
yes it is in fact it is
good this dollar interpretation of
the member states which choose the vaccine
it's enough it's enough it's weird
but hey we'll have the opportunity to
talk about it again but my question is different,
that is to say
madam president during the hate at
the moment and is in the process of making
iron publicity between guy even useful the
representative of biotech for africa
and not only for africa
and i understand very well that there is
biotech with fiennes alan are the
biggest suppliers of the
european union but is that the  commission
shouldn't be neutral towards
vaccine manufacturers
that's actually my question it's a
bit like uefa you see renting fab
odom hundreds of millions of euros in
advertising for your
green grain campaign  deal and  after you support
politically at the wef a when there is the
super league kiki who try to
translate fans into competition in the
sector of major football competitions
then there we have the big supplier of
the european union and who is german
like the president  and who the president
will promote in the world and to
my love that's my question is that there is
not a duty of neutrality with regard
to private pharmaceutical companies on
the part
of the european commission and its
president
david  so once again the president
was in africa carrying a message
is of a package of important support
with regard to vaccines
vaccination is the capacity to
produce vaccines for africa in the medium
term therefore with a set of
immediate action and also to lay the foundations
of a local capacity which is very
important for Africans there are
several technologies of
rêva kz1 products which have been developed there
last  ment it happens that one of these
technologies was at the origin of the vaccine which were
the most sold in the european union
and perhaps even in the world but I
lack the figures to support
his stéphane is still in the process  to
look for
but I can also send them to you
by email after once again the
European Commission is neutral and
agnostic with regard to
vaccine technologies which should be
reused in Europe or elsewhere
but it is up to
vaccine producers who are willing and  who are
willing to invest and invest
in research in the capacity to
produce vaccines in africa and here
it is
for the project that you mention
cybertech it does not exclude other
companies which if they wish to
s  invest in africa or elsewhere
in latin america or in other
parts of the world which forgets to
partners who have the interest
to increase their capacity to
produce vaccines we will be  we're very very
pleased to
partner with private sector partners international
organizations civil society funding bodies
to support efforts
to increase this
production capacity so hopefully the
response was clear and impacted  to all
the points that you will raise
and the exact figures agreed after
the opinion of the briefings because stéphane
has synchronization problems
so has stéphanie in the figures so you
can go up for the data
hello indeed I had small
problems of  synchronization but it's
typical with me haiti me it's like
the relationship between cro magnon and a
computer so it's not going very well that
being said yes we have a delivery
of 1.4 billion doses in total
so far  and it's true that
the biotech files company delivered the
majority of the twelve you're a member
we're almost at 700 million doses
while the other companies said we
book is a little less obviously
but the total is 1.4 billion
doses that have been delivered. This figure must also be
taken into consideration in this figure, of
course, the donations that have been
made within the framework of the mechanism for
sharing vaccines with the rest of the
world thank you thank you very much stéphane
does he have any other questions for
us today yes gred
25 dollars by selling
titles or cantons green pass
madam president to treat me go
in match lens tier 1 no contacts
before  it's all over
it was
six years ago 5 th
[Music]
if he
accepts from
bottom to
top
[Music]
yes yes to kris technaute had directed
obtain
precise anne bocskai
press release of john
fox arrive all fixed
experian to me
explain